eine frage wird immer wichtiger als
anhand der steigenden langsam aber doch
steigenden zahl der geimpften was dürfen
eigentlich geimpfte bekommen die alle
grundrechte endlich zurück auch dazu
wurde die kanzlerin heute gefragt in dem
ich bin nach dem falschen wort was sie
auch schon benutzt habe privilegien
gefragt worden das haben sie ihm nicht
gesagt denn daran dürfen wir uns nicht
gewöhnen dass das normale leben wie wir
es kennen mit neuen freiheiten
das leben ist was nicht mehr normal ist
da wollen wir wieder hin das sind die
grundrechte und die hat jeder aber im
augenblick ist es noch so dass selbst
wenn jemand geimpft ist nicht klar ist
ob nicht eine ansteckung trotzdem
anderer personen erfolgen kann und
solange das nicht geklärt ist können wir
überhaupt keine besonderen maßnahmen
oder rechte hin zu den normalen rechten
für klare regeln geben dass sie ja schon
geneigt zu sagen im rechtsstaat schauen
sie es gibt jetzt sehr viele klagen von
menschen die geimpft werden wollen in
der höchsten priorität class es gibt
klagen über die gerechtigkeit der
maßnahmen ist wird klagen geben über die
frage von rechten für geimpfte das
gehört zum rechtsstaat und das da müssen
wir argumentieren als politik warum wir
etwas machen warum wir etwas nicht
machen
ich glaube wenn wir später sehr vielen
menschen ein angebot gemacht haben
können zum impfen und dann sagen manche
menschen wir waren ja keine impfpflicht
dann sagen manche menschen jetzt möchte
ich nicht gegeben werden
dann muss man vielleicht schon solche
unterschiede machen und sagen okay wer
das nicht möchte der kann vielleicht
auch bestimmte dinge nicht machen
klaus ich würde sagen nachdem ich das
gehört da brauche ich ja nicht gar keine
frage zu stellen
du wirst bestimmt eine prägnante meinung
dazu haben das ist schon also die
herleitung finde ich absolut
nachvollziehbar ich freu mich dass die
bundeskanzlerin sagt grundrechte sind
ein hoher wert wie sie dann mit der
einschränkung von grundrechten umgeht in
der verbindung mit sich impfen lassen
können dem impfangebot ist schon
knifflig sie sagt es zwar nicht wörtlich
aber es schwingt schon mit ein
verständnis dafür dass man ein
verständnis dafür aufbringen müsse wenn
sich jemand nicht impfen lasse dass der
dann gewisse nachteile im
öffentlichen leben hat und bestimmte
grundrechte möglicherweise nicht mehr
ausüben kann
das finde ich schon weitgehend
weitreichend aber es entspricht doch der
realität wenn wir ganz kurz das auf die
politische debatte beziehen wir haben in
der eu eine debatte erlebt um einen
brief den der tschechische
ministerpräsident mit zu tages
geschrieben hat der zwar für die andere
seite argumentiert hat und gesagt hat
dann braucht es sonderrechte das
bedeutet dabei am ende derjenige der nur
nicht krone hatte oder derjenige der zb
noch nicht geimpft ist darf in gewisse
urlaubsregionen nicht oder er darf nicht
in ein flugzeug einsteigen also ich
glaube die kanten und wollte damit nur
ausdrücken was ohnehin in der wirtschaft
passieren wird denn man wird ja nicht
weiter sozusagen auf wirtschaft
verzichten und ein risiko eingehen wenn
man sagen kann leute entweder ihr könnt
zum beispiel hier ein 1 1 test abgeben
ihr könnt sagen ihr seid geimpft oder
oder ihr hattet das virus schon aber ich
glaube der springende punkt ist dass das
nicht der staat vor geben darf sondern
dass das eine frage der wirtschaft und
des individuellen verhaltens ist wir
diskutieren ja gelegentlich über eine
bar wenn ein barbetreiber sagt also ich
hab mir das alles überlegt ich möchte
gern den impfausweis sehen und nur wenn
geimpftes darf in meine bar finde ich ok
dann hat er entweder full house weil die
leute sagen da fühle ich mich sicher
oder geht pleite weil die leute sagen
was ich glaube der spinnt da gehe ich in
die bahn neben dran
da kann ich auch ohne impfausweis rein
so stelle ich mir das vor wenn aber
plötzlich des gastronomie gesetz
vorschreibt dass sozusagen alle
gaststätten aus dem sinne einer eines
hygiene konzept die impfung voraussetzen
müssen dass man reinkommt dann geht es
für mich ein wirklich zu weit
da hat der staat nichts damit zu tun
wir sind
und wir liefern dir deine news auf
youtube zum nächsten video kommst du
hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren